all right it's just about uh half past
six legend gentleman colleagues so we'll
start the committee meeting just a
reminder that we're on youtube this time
again so uh people out there can have us
tv audience will be able to see us
uh
the first item is uh attendances
and just wait turns joe are there any
apologies councillor morgan chair
uh much about castle
no that's true yeah i've had apologies
from councillor morgan but no others
okay
well you may arrive later
can i just just welcome the new members
of the committee i know council wetton
been on this before in fact you were
chair of it weren't you
i thought yes it obviously burned into
my memory that i was i was a member and
you were the chair at the time but
welcome all to
completely new members as well
also who are not here yet but welcome to
them anyway
okay and so item two is the memberships
which we've all been uh circulated with
there
item three is terms of reference
on which on pages two and three three
and three and six can we just agree
those
there's no change
item four questions from members of the
public
non-received chair nom received thanks
very much
item five declarations of interest
anybody everybody knows how that works
so you can give it and declared interest
if you have one
item six is minutes of the meeting the
22nd of march
uh which uh consummate who was there
apart from myself give her
move it and second it
thanks very much councillor carter
thanks so much moved and seconded we
agree those
item seven which came i think on the
supplementary agenda is the draft annual
governance statement
i'm told the director of legal might be
doing this but i'm not quite sure
the director of legal and governance on
this occasion uh so yeah just um going
through the report that was
as you say circulated as part of the
supplementary agenda um it just contains
the draft annual governance statement
which is um
for you to consider
and approve before it's published on the
31st of july uh the draft will then be
reviewed um
and a final final version will be put
together and published no later than the
30th of november um so yes the it can be
asked to concentrate um this year's
annual governance statement
comes through each year and follows the
same format as usual um it has three
sections uh the first section is um a
brief summary of the
activities that the council have done
during the year that demonstrate um how
the council has met
each of the sit for um
principles
the second
section is a review of how the council
has addressed significant governance
issues identified in the previous year's
annual governance statement and the
third and final section is a section
which lays out
the significant governance issues for
the coming year
um so yes if anyone has any questions on
that i'm happy to say them
any questions from members
no oh
okay thanks alex you've got away lightly
with that thanks very much
we're on to item uh
item eight the audit strategy memorandum
uh which i think is uh karen from uh
massage
it is thank you chair
um so the document you've got in front
of you tonight is the audit strategy
memorandum or the audit plan if you
prefer that that terminology it covers
the work that we need to do on two areas
which is the accounts and our audit of
the uh the council's financial
statements and then secondly in respect
of your arrangements for uh value for
money if i talk first about the accounts
now i won't go through the plan um page
by page i'll just pull out the key
messages and i may sound very similar to
conversations you've heard me um may
have before it is a risk-based plan and
when we're talking about the accounts
that is um for me about the risk that
there's an error in those accounts that
is material and by material we mean big
enough to be misleading to someone who
wants to place reliance on your accounts
so you'll see in section 8 of the
document that we've set out how we
calculate materiality and provided the
information that you might need to be
satisfied that that is done
appropriately but essentially we set it
with reference to your expenditure
because that's the bit that is of
interest taxpayers really it's what the
council spends um rather than anything
else that the council does and so you
will see that we've set materiality at
the planning stage as 11.5 million for
the for the council and slightly higher
for the group
um we do obviously set a lower level of
materiality for some things that are
considered to be more sensitive and in
particular for your uh disclosures in
respect of senior officer remuneration
because clearly it will be inappropriate
to have those rights the nearest 11
million pounds and we want those to be
absolutely right because they're of
interest to uh to taxpayers
and to other organizations and you'll
see that we also set what we call a
trivial limits we don't bring everything
to your attention as those charged with
governance we try and have a sense of
proportionality about that so we will
tend to report to you anything that's
above 347 thousand pounds just so you're
clear about the um the degree of
accuracy if you like or the derivative
correctness in those accounts in the in
the first instance
lots of what's in the report is
technical that i'm required to report to
you but the key thing from your side is
to be clear about and understand the
risk areas that we've identified
so there are um
three things that we've identified as
significant risks and respects for
council's accounts the first of those is
around the management override of
controls i tell you every year that this
is one of the things that professional
standards require us to
focus our attention on but it isn't
because i'm worried about the way in
which management operates in trafford
per se it is simply that it is the area
where management's ability to influence
the numbers in the accounts and how they
look at the end um would need to be uh
covered off so we look at things like
where management have made estimates or
whether they've used judgments to
determine whether something should or
shouldn't be reflected in the accounts
and we look at journals that have been
posted to make sure that we understand
how management are moving things from
one place in those accounts to another
the second area that we look at is the
net defined pension liability
that's because it's a very big number it
moves a lot it's a really complicated
basis of calculation and you are reliant
on an external expert that's the
actuary
who provides you with the information
that you put in the account so we look
at in particular at how the actuaries
arrived at the the information that
they've provided back to you
um the the third area that we've
identified is in respect to property
plants and equipment valuation
i need to be absolutely clear because i
think the plan doesn't make explicit
that this is also in respect of your
investment properties so it's not just
the operational stuff and in fact if
anything there's a probably a bigger
risk in in my mind at least with
evaluation of investment properties
since they are done on a different basis
again those are very big numbers in the
concept context of the council's
operation and the basis of calculating
them the fact that they're an estimate
you're relying on a valuer
and the value exercises their judgment
and so on and means that they are an
area that we need to pay a particular
focus uh to
there are then some other areas that are
probably slightly less
risky from my perspective in terms of
material error but equally are complex
so you've got the manchester airport
shareholding and again you'll be aware
that you rely on an expert to provide
you with that information and to include
that in your accounts it's a complex
valuation so we will spend some time
looking at that and there is the way in
which you'll keep your pfi schemes i
think over time we will see that
diminishes the risk as the pfi
liability reduces and then finally the
last thing that we've identified in
there is is around the group
consolidation so how you decide what
other bits of the council's operation
that you do need to consolidate where
you're working in in partnership or in
some arrangement with a third party
what the audit strategy memorandum does
is sets out for you how at this stage we
plan to do our work to get the assurance
it doesn't set out for you all of the
work that we do on other things in the
council's accounts like the payroll
system and so on because we are less
concerned about the risk of them being
materially wrong
but as you know because you've seen our
audit completion reports that come back
at the end
when we come back at the end we will
tell you what we found uh not just
against these risks but against all of
the other matters arising through the
course of the audit so we you know we'll
we'll report to everything that that
comes up over uh that 347 thousand pound
trivial limit that i mentioned earlier
the report then goes on to talk about
value for money and just to be clear
that although this is a risk-based
process what we are talking about here
is the arrangements that the council has
in place
to to make sure that it is delivering
the three e's
we are required by the national audit
office to look at that in the context of
three criteria which are your financial
sustainability your governance and then
your what they call improving three e's
which is um essentially uh uh can be
paraphrased that's what you're doing to
use your performance management system
your cost information and so on
and your partnership working to improve
the services that you're providing for
the residents of trafford
you will and indeed businesses in
trafford you will see that we are
required to identify for you any areas
where we think there is a risk that your
arrangements may be
weak a significant weakness in those
arrangements and as you are aware we
reported to you last year around your
arrangements for children's services
because of your ofsted report so we
identify weaknesses in respect of that
performance management criteria and also
in terms of governance and decision
making
particularly around children's services
so we flag that for you now as a
continuing risk
in terms of your arrangements but we
will of course over the course of uh the
period that we're doing our work
continue to monitor um what you are
doing in response to it and what the
regulators who have uh a remit there so
often in particular um are saying about
the arrangements that the council has in
place
i'm probably gonna stop talking there
but i'm happy to take any questions if
if there are any um bearing in mind that
we do come back later to report to you
on our findings
thanks very much currently any questions
very extensive report
sorry casa carter
good evening thanks karen um you talked
a bit about the risk inherent in
valuation of property including
investments
and it's noticeable on that
chart that it's
the most probable i'm getting that right
could you specifically in relation to
investments could you just um
give a bit more context and information
on that please
so so this is about the value that those
um properties whether they are
investment properties or they are invest
or their operational properties are
reflected in your financial statements
um the
the way in which valuers arrive at their
valuations are really very complex and
if i think about your investment
properties they're required to value
them on on effectively what is a
fair value
so that will involve all sorts of
complicated things like looking at
leases that you might have in place for
uh people who are occupying those those
properties uh how much square footage
each one's got what the length of the
lease is what options you've given them
around renewals or rent-free periods and
all of those kinds of things and it all
builds up in a fairly complex way to
give you a kind of overall value
so the reason that we identify as a
significant risk is that it doesn't take
the valuer it doesn't take much given
the scale of your property holdings for
the value to have misunderstood
something or misapplied something or
even just made a simple arithmetic error
that that snowballs up into
a material amount
i think in previous years we have had
some issues with the best evaluation we
have seen significant changes to
valuations that have been reflected in
your accounts but what we saw last year
i think was a real step up in the
quality of the information the value was
provided to support those valuations
nevertheless it remains a kind of um an
ongoing issue that it doesn't take much
for it to be quite significantly wrong
i think probably the other thing um to
add is that you do your valuations um
excluding your investment properties
just thinking about your operational
property you have what's known as a
five-year revaluation program
and there is therefore an adjustment
that you need to make every year
to the valuations that the valuer has
given you to make sure that they remain
materially correct when they haven't
been subject to a formal revaluation and
that in itself can be quite complicated
and can be affected by the proportion of
your asset base that is subject to
valuation now that issue doesn't supply
on your investment properties because
you do revalue them every year so it's
it's kind of different things at
different places in the accounts if that
makes sense
thank you i'm taking from that that
you're not
waving a red flag at who's just saying
this is part of your work
yeah it is a risk that will appear in
i would hazard a guess 99 of local
authority accounts
thanks very much anybody else mike
can i just ask in in terms of the um the
valuation of the shareholding in in the
airport
group um
obviously that the airport's been in a
pretty chaotic
state of flux for for a while now
um and hopefully it's um rising
out of that i'm sure it is
um but what
points
do you
actually take what sort of date do you
choose to take a
valuation and how do you
deal with a situation like that one
which is
a company that is so these are your
accounts
and it is the value you the valuation
that you put in there on that
shareholding is the valuation that is
provided to you by the expert that you
rely on to do that work for you
it is a firm that you use called bdo all
the local authorities in greater
manchester that own the similar
shareholding to you so that's everybody
except the city council uses the same
valuation basis
um bdo have access to lots and lots of
the operating information about the
airport and the way in which they um you
know the cash flows are working and so
on and so forth in order to
use a fairly complex valuation model to
arrive at a figure
that they think reflects the value of
the airport and they do that at a point
in time based on the airport's draft
accounts for the year
when we come and do our audit work at
the end that the airport's financial
year will have ended its accounts will
have been audited uh formally and we
will look at whether there's any
difference between
effectively what what was predicted and
what actually happened
i think it's probably fair to say that
over the last few years you've seen that
valuation move up and down because of
the impacts of corvid and that's
probably what you would expect so there
was a big fall
in the value that was reflected near
accounts in 21 because it was based on
what happened through 2020
um but that started to come back up last
year and again this year as because
which i only know because i've seen the
valuation report um it's coming back up
because the airport is getting back on a
firmer and more sustainable footing and
i think if you've got any more questions
about the valuation they're probably
better answered by graham than me
um because my role is is linked to how
did you get to that place and is it
reasonable and i use a valuation expert
on my side to challenge the valuation
expert that you've used because it is a
it is a very complex model based on
income floors income streams the size of
areas and and so on it's it's a hugely
complex model is there anything
eventually it's very complex i know
we've used bdo for a number of years
obviously i think oldham commissioned
them on behalf of all of us
um and so it's a similar valuation
reflected in everybody's accounts well
of nine of the districts office of
manchester because they're holding big
evaluation
thank you
thanks very much not to anybody else so
thanks karen i think item nine external
audit progress report is also you i
think
oh muhammad mohammed's got to do that
thank you
thank you chair um good evening everyone
um
it's not a lengthy document it's just
quite
a summary of
what we have
delivered as a responsibility as
external auditor
if you go to page 52
of your pack um the
only outstanding item from 2021 is our
all of the government accounts
um
we have
the treasury have
issued their instruction
about
the submission of required for that
reporting threshold but we are still
waiting for our uh regulator national
our group instruction from national
audit office before we and a group
approach
to carry out our
review of the wga work
prepared by the uh by the council
um until this is not complete um we
the audit certificate remains um
outstanding
um
from
our perspective this is the only item
from 20 20 20 21 remains outstanding
um
for 21 22 um karen just presented the
audit strategy memorandum we have
completed our planning for 2122
um and developed the audit strategy
memorandum which ken has presented um we
are planning to come
on site or to do our final or field work
in october november
um
from in section two um this is which is
uh page 53 onward is
just for your information a summary of
recent national national reports and
publications uh for your information
that that's if you have any questions
thanks very much any questions on that
could i just ask about this
2021 wga
that's a wait wait you're waiting for
the treasury it's nothing to do with you
or us is it
yeah so
there are two elements of wga one is
treasury one is national audit office so
the tragedy has issued their
instruction
um
across all the local government we are
waiting for
the national audit office because they
we
we carried out the group instruction
approach as per the national audit
office so we don't know what approach we
need to take to review the wga
to give you the certificate that it's
okay to submit
so that's the outstanding item so we are
waiting for
yes
waiting for guns thanks very much
anybody all the questions anybody
no well thanks karen thank you
item
10 treasury management annual
performance 20 21 22 report
is that you graham
i'm doing anything that's me thanks joe
so this is the treasury management
annual performance report for
2122
and in this report you'll find an update
of the performance of the treasury
management function of the council
in the year the levels of debts
investments sent into
an update on the wider economic factors
of the year
and changes in interest rates
so in terms of the economic
factors of 21 22. after two years
dominate by covid the main story was the
growth in inflation and the subsequent
increase in
the banking base rate
we had been projecting an increase in
the base rate but not at the rate that
we've received in the end
this spent towards the end of the year
both the cost of borrowing and the
investment zone increased
but relatively minimal in 21 22 the real
brunt of that impact will occur in 22-23
so in terms of the performance of the um
of the team there was an overspending
year
in the budget of 927 thousands um
the majority of this is attributable to
the council's investment at the airport
uh there was a shortfall in the in the
income in the year of
392.
um added to a
provision of the same figure for
at 22.23 for the anticipated shortfall
that we're thinking will happen again
next year
um
in terms of borrowing in the year um
debt levels reduced by 57 million
from
31st of march 21 to the same point at
the end of last year
this includes an early repayment of 27.8
million to the pwlb
as a result of a debt restructure which
was carried out in the year
the um the debt restructure was funded
from an early repayment from the cis
tower investment
the average interest cost of debt was
2.82 and 21.22 which is a small increase
from
22.57
of same figure in 20 20 21
investment levels increased in year from
97.3 million to 230.6 million movement
of 3.3
this is due to increased levels of cash
out
and
the average rate of return for
investments in the year was
0.35 which is lower than the 0.76 in the
previous year
but we still managed to achieve a higher
return on that investment than that than
what was predicted for the year
and then so finally
for the potential indicators i can
confirm that the council didn't breach
any of its potential limits or
indicators
in 21 22.
that's many thanks to
thanks very much frank anyway questions
on that report anybody comes to carter
[Music]
i don't thank you i don't know if it's
in your um remit to look forward as well
as back but in an environment of
likely increases in interest rates
what impact might that have on trafford
please
[Music]
pretty good question i think
just break it down into components i
think there's a few there
increasing interest rates
in terms of the existing debt we've got
probably little impact with the majority
of that debts fixed rate debt so very
little impact i think
what we what we're mindful of is
is new debt that we would be looking to
take on so you said well what do we take
the new debt out for while we take new
debt to support aspects of the capital
program
so if you think about the leisure
strategy probably about the biggest
as well as our asset investment strategy
where we are um
[Music]
when we make investments through their
finance through borrowing as well so
those increases are something we need to
be mindful of obviously in terms of
looking at the business cases around
trafford leisure
and the investments around that looking
at the business cases for future
investments through the investment
strategy it has a bearing there i think
on a positive note
obviously we have and you've heard from
frank there we have a lot of cash that
we invest through the treasury
management function
um
increases to investment rates increases
the amounts of returns we get from those
investments as well
so i think those are probably some of
the more notable ones
thanks ever so much graeme um
so when you're looking at future
business cases and and anticipating a
potential rise in interest rates is that
how is that scrutinized and is that
subject to order
i think what we do
what we what we've what we've got to be
really mindful of i think is
what point do we think we're going to
borrow
um
we use treasury investment advisors to
provide projections of interest rates
so we just make sure we factor in a
prudent level there's no point factoring
in a level that's going to be too
to
enhance what the business case looks
like we need to make a prudent level
based on those estimates and forecasts
from investment advisors within those
business cases
okay that
coastal button
[Music]
um i'm not i'm looking at the
chart um 4.2 um with the breakdown of
the
the debt compared to the previous year
and there's some sort of interesting
dynamics
in
in that and i'm sure i don't understand
what's
behind all of those
dynamics as it as we sit here at the
moment but
in simple terms the
the debt figure
has been quite substantially reduced
um by about 58 million pounds i think
you mentioned that figure didn't you
and
at the same time the
investments figure
has gone up by
33
million
and yet
i don't think it was trafford that won
the lottery today was it so
um i just wondered
i know there's lots of money moving
around like this there's always money
coming into the council equally there's
always money going out to the council
and there's
um various
um
debts that due for um sometimes due for
repayment and sometimes that's a long
way off
and
investments are
um
made as and when um but what what's the
sort of the chief
thrust behind those big move big figures
that are
in the they're showing us movements on
that particular chart
i'll tell you that i think
what's what happens with dead in a
normal year is that
either
we have a maturity profile for debt
repayment so there could be some
some amounts of debt repayment last few
years that's probably been relatively
small i think
therefore what happens with the rest
what happens with the debt balance
ordinarily well it would increase if we
needed to take on new debt to fund
some aspects of the capital program
i think last year from memory there was
not any significant amount of that and i
think
what we're seeing is
and historically when we've talked debt
to fund the capital investment it's been
fairly long-term debt
i think
when we embarked on the asset investment
strategy
um
about three years ago
the debt that we took on to fund some of
those investments in some cases were
quite short-term debt
so
if those investment facilities have now
ended and we've had repayments we use
them repayments to repay debt and that's
been the fact to why that debt has moved
in the air and reduced down so it's just
investments that have matured through
the investment strategy where we've been
repaid back as a council and we've
repaid the debt back that we needed to
borrow to fund that investment
i think
going to the investment side and the
overall cash position
sometimes it's difficult to understand
but i think the reason we old
investments is
does feel more short-term so we've got
investments and cash that we invest
through treasury
that
obviously is money that's backing up our
reserves
and we know how we've used reserves in
the past obviously got quite specific
reserves but we've been been using
reserves probably to a larger extent in
the last couple of years to to support
our revenue budget but i think
some of the big items that have caused
it to move and i think two probably
notable ones and we'll come on to it one
of the next items is within the budget
monitor you'll notice for the out turn
report that there was quite a
significant underspend on the capital
programme
so
if you think the majority of the capital
program is funded from external grant
we've probably received the grant in
advance and if the program slipped we've
not spent it so that's that's cash to
swell those investment figures
and the other thing i think has been as
a result of corvid the council got
some quite large substantial sums that
it gave businesses so business grants
and depending on the take-up and the
timing of that take-up has meant if
we've been paid the cash upfront which
is what local government wanted we
didn't want to be out of pocket giving
grants out so the government paid us up
front
um and that's just added to some of
those investment balances so i think so
those are some are probably the key the
key items on those
[Music]
a further question if i may just
again on the on the dynamics of
on that same chart
the
um the total debt comes
down by the 58 million
um
and at the same time that cfr figure
that come comes down
does that happen in
in tandem
or or they got their own
um
dynamics affecting
[Music]
them
what i'm getting at is that leads to the
calculation of
whether or not we were under borrowed
yeah
and
um so
what's behind my question is
if they if they don't move in in sort of
parallel is there a
was there a chance that during that
period we did become overborrowed
just
yeah just to explain that the cfr which
is obvious that's
cfr is called that's called the capital
finance requirement so
what we need to borrow for our capital
programme feeds into that
the level of debt
there is one of our prudential
indicators does say
what's your debt level compared to your
capital finance requirements and the
reason and rationale for that being as a
prudential indicator is exactly that
point councillor in that what we don't
want to be is in a position where we are
overborrowed so we don't want external
debt bigger than the cfr
um and and that's what we try to monitor
um
through that
so the reduction in debt does translate
through the cfr um
[Music]
so you see comparable reductions in that
so they are
running
they are linked to now
if you
if we started trafford from scratch and
said the first thing we did was borrow
10 million pounds to invest in an asset
the cfr would be 10 million and if we
borrowed it the debt would be 10 million
i think what what you've got is
sometimes the decision to borrow
and physically take the cash out
will be done it's not necessarily done
at the time you would make the
investment into the asset because you
may have cash sat in your bank
so if you've if you've got
surplus cash you may decide to delay
that borrowing until market conditions
are more favorable to you and that feeds
into this under borrowed position
but ordinarily you would expect to see
movements in debt broadly reflected by
similar movements in this cfr but there
are anomalies and a lot of that's caused
by the timing that you physically take
on that external debt
if you may just ask a very basic
question next i know that the ideal
situation is that we
are always under borrowed
what
happens if
even for a
brief time
um
the council
is deemed to be overborrowed is is there
so does it affect his sort of credit
ratings and that sort of thing or what
sort of impact is there on the council
for a short
time of uh overborrowing overborrowing
i think the biggest thing
that i would want to consider in in a
scenario like that and and that's not to
say
we're not allowed to have that position
where the cfr
is less than the actual external level
of debt
but you wouldn't want it for any
prolonged period and i think one of the
one of the
big reasons for that is that
how are you paying your debt charges
and it's the cost of that debt holding
that you'd be mindful of
in a situation like that
so i think
temporarily
it's not necessarily an issue
there may be a scenario for example that
the business case around for example a
future capital investment
it may be
prudent to actually borrow the amount
slightly in advance and if that amount
spanned year-end you could end up having
a level of debt bigger than the cfr
because you've not physically spent that
money but you've taken advantage of
preferential rates in the market knowing
that you are going to invest that
through your program
but the issue you would have to consider
is in doing that
what's you your temporary funding
position on that borrowing that you've
done in advance so
i think from my point of view you will
probably want to try and avoid that
scenario as much as you can but that's
not to say it won't arise but you would
try to limit that period of time that
you were in that position if it did
thank you
thanks for bros council thompson
thank you
just going back to the capital grants
that haven't been spent i guess they sit
in our bank accounts gaining
some interest
but with the rate of inflation now i
guess
at the length of those grants in our
bank account the less buying power they
have do we monitor that and make sure
that that grant will still be fit to
buy of the assets that we want
[Music]
i think
it's a really valid question i think we
do historically we have where we've
had grants or contributions and they've
rested in the bank account until such
point that we need to spend six twelve
months in our in the future whatever
we have in the past included interest
calculations on top
to increase that grant amount to
maintain the buying power
i think what you've got now though at
the moment is a big mismatch haven't you
that your buying power's gone down that
quick the way inflation has gone yes
interest rates are rising but it's
it's not half a pound is it the
net loss in value i suppose i mean
um when we do the period four monitor
we're going to try and bring some of
those aspects around inflation and its
impact on the capital program out a
little bit more
um we've done it for revenue as part of
the first budget monitor and the out
turn report but i think the capital is a
different thing because obviously
how does that rising inflation impact on
our play shape and aspirations as a
council is something we've got to
consider particularly going back to
councillor carter's question about
impact on business cases um
[Music]
in economic terms we
normally considered
deficit financing is
is a very important tool for economic
growth
and number two
so we don't consider
that borrowing in economic term is a bad
thing because
spending more means more economic growth
so
do you think as a council
we consider deficit francine is good for
us for future
so how do you how do you
explain it thank you
i think there's two aspects in there
nationally
um
obviously national budgeting and that's
what gives the authority funding through
the national settlements for local
government i think
as a local authority we govern by
slightly different rules around what we
can borrow for so we wouldn't borrow for
anything other than day to day uh sorry
we wouldn't borrow for day-to-day
expenditure we would only borrow
for assets that yield benefits in future
years
um
and we don't borrow and go into deficit
we're not allowed to go into deficit as
such so we we set a balanced budget and
we only borrow when it's prudent
affordable and sustainable to do so so
nationally that might be one way of
balancing and
their economics but it's not something
we would do as a local authority or are
allowed to do
okay but
spending more
on productive
purposes
is a good sign of local
economy to grow
am i right
absolutely yes yeah yes that's it yeah
yeah
anybody
else another questions
okay so we're going to item 11 which is
a budget monitoring report
is that you going to be you graham or
frank
yeah okay yeah i'll say that report yeah
just scroll through
yeah so this
budget out turn reports went to
executive in june um
i think there's a bit of a narrative to
it in the
what happened during 21 22
we had been projecting
um reasonable levels of overspend
probably in the region of about two and
a half million pound period six at
period eight
that's
um
the months that we reported
the outer position was quite favorable
in them we we actually understand budget
by 1.5 million and i think
that's in part because of the way that
that budget position was managed through
the year so
we introduced um to try to manage that
position as part of clt
some measures around recruitment
um
to try to balance that position i think
whilst we've got an underspend of 1.5
million i think what the challenging
issue is that we've got is that
with local authority budgets which cover
a lot of areas we've got some areas of
the budget that
there are recurrent budget pressures
that we've seen
develop and continue to develop
notable ones being children's placement
costs and home to school transport
and i think
they still exist we've got to out to
them by
offsetting some of those pressures by
one-off type savings and i think that's
the that's the difficulty we've got when
we're looking at
how does this impact on our budgets
going forward
um
i think that's difficult i think just
some of the
notable headlines within this report so
whilst we understand by 1.5 million
if i look at the impacts for example of
colvid
we did see that obviously continuing in
21 22.
we did budget for that
impact
but the budget we did set was slightly
lower than actually the adverse impact
we saw
i think we've noted in the report about
half a million pound of additional
predominantly income losses um around
car park income planning income and
things like that that contributed to an
india pressure there
i think another area around the
investment strategy
that
just to clarify the investment strategy
we do budget for
benefit from that strategy um to give us
broadly about seven million pound of net
income per year
and whilst we achieve good levels of
income we didn't achieve budget so we're
about a million pounds short of our net
income target so
that was
something that built
into that out term position i think
just on that what what we've done in
terms of budgeting for
income from the asset strategy is just
we've got to be quite mindful that the
levels of income we've got i think are
probably at a level that we don't really
want to exceed because it's quite
difficult particularly where we've got
short-term investments that mature
to them reinvest those amounts and
maintain that similar level of income so
that's quite difficult for us i think
if i just talk about adults services um
pressures on client costs
were evident not the same
magnitude as children
i think the big thing on on adult social
care during the year was how we maintain
the provision of
uh bed spaces to allow through put in
the acute sectors
um
and what we were able to do was maximize
and and claim against national grants
that were available for that
um and we did that and maximized that
income during the year
um
what that's allowed us to do because
those grants nationally have stopped
but put the demand from the acute sector
to get people out of hospitals not
stopped
that buildup of income and we've put
that into reserve has allowed us to
carry on an element of provision in 2223
um
just in terms of reserves
again earmarked reserves there's a table
in the report around earmarked reserves
you'll see that there's been an increase
of
just over 17 million
there's a couple of items in that that
are quite lumpy in terms of covered
reserves and business rate reserves
that have explained that these meetings
before
if i strip those out
earmarked reserves have increased by
about eight million pounds
and the the factors that have
contributed to that is obviously the
underspend of 1.5 million
we got a better outcome performance on
business rate income and council tax
income
we did receive some government grants
that we were able to actually apply to
some of our base budget expenditure
which released budget that we've put
into reserves
and the other thing is around the adult
services
what i just said around d2a and i think
just to qualify what i'm talking about
reserves and how we're putting money in
i think
it's all done in a view
to keep our resilience as strong as we
can do and bolster our reserves for
what's coming in terms of our budget
planning for for 23 for and beyond
um just a couple of other items that
must bring to your attention i think is
the
the rising impact of inflation
is a real
um
challenge and difficulty for us going
into into 22 23.
within this report we we made an
estimate of what that impact would be
for 22 23.
the and the big ticket items there are
how is our inflation is going to affect
public sector pay and we heard yesterday
around the settlements for teachers and
nurses or the
indicative settlements um
and and what impact it will have on
energy costs but we are not
blinking to think that's
just going to be the sole impact it will
be wider than that things like home to
school transport contracts are under
pressure as well so we have created
an inflation risk reserve
of three million pound and we think
we're probably going to have to dip into
some of the contingency budgets in 2223
to mitigate that
um
just in respect to the capital programme
i think it's fair to say that the
out-turn performance felt a little bit
disappointing
um
in terms of the levels of slippage that
have been reported through the year and
i think
as officers
we're really mindful that the capital
program delivers council councils
priorities
so we've set up a capital programme
working group just to try and monitor
and track that progress more closely
throughout the year
and finally just in terms of schools and
the dedicated schools grant
what we've got is an issue that
we've now gone into deficit on our
schools dsg budget
and what's driving that is
solely down to the pressure we're seeing
coming through the high needs block so
the pressure that all our special
schools and the provision of
the placement costs for outable
replacements and people who've got
special educational needs
is quite severe
um our deficit
has just gone into deficit uh at the end
of this financial year only marginally
far better place than a lot of
authorities but it's something that we
need to watch um and try to manage that
position
at the moment governments say in respect
of our schools accounting keep that
separate from your own general fund
accounting
um
but it's a bit of a fluid situation at
the moment that we've just had some
government white papers green papers on
scn and schools and we're still waiting
for announcements around that separation
beyond 22-23 so
um it gives you a flavor of what's going
on there's quite a bit at the moment i
think just to add what i'll do this week
we've got
going to the executive on tuesday our
period two budget monitor for 22 23 so
what i'll do
obviously it's not timely to bring to
this meeting because it's not gone to
the exit yet but i'll distribute that
as soon after the executive as i can and
give a bit of an update
um where we are projected at early point
in 2223.
um thank you everyone happy to take
questions chair
just to mention that um
monitor report that graeme mentioned
will of course have already been
circulated to all members
for the agenda on monday yeah totally
right john i'll send it out after this
meeting if that's the case yep yeah of
course
okay
a couple of questions if i may uh
graham as a um
a long-term
observer of the budget monitoring
um
figures
um it's interesting
over the years what these sort of
trends that you see
there and and
in in general terms if you
if you're looking at the
performance of the directorates
um
somewhere up some are down
overall it tends to
bring in a reasonable result at the end
end of the year
um and it's not always the same ones
that are the uh the guilty ones not
always the same ones who are the the
good boys
um
but what i do notice is i think
council-wide budgets pretty much always
come in underspent
um
is that because they're sort of
constructed that way so that you've got
a little bit of
extra in the locker when if things do
get rough
if i i'll leave
leave that question
stop there with that question if i may
then i want to ask you something about
council tax
i think just said
you're right the council-wide budgets
are
quite a variety of different activity
but it's where we hold
things like the treasury management
budget it's where we have held in the
last couple of years things like the
different array of corvid grants that
we've had
it's where we hold our general
contingency budgets
so
i think you're probably right and it's
it it does tend to be the area that
and quite rightly so if the
contingencies are there because we don't
spread the contingencies across all our
service areas we hold them in that
council-wide area so
it tends to be the the bailout area
of our budgets i think
as part of the budget planning for 23 24
i suppose
the issue we do have is that if you look
at the size of the budget and the size
of the budget for 22 23 in that budget
terms is about 190 million
so this
i won't defend
holding the levels of contingencies we
do we would probably hold a general
contingency of about 2 million pounds
um
so if nothing else happens you'll see an
underspend on council by budgets of 2
million
when i release that contingency but i do
use it i used it last year for example
to pay for a pay award that we didn't
budget for on the basis that
we were told there was going to be a
public sector pay freeze
so that never happened so that did eat
into contingency so
it's where we've got that little bit of
flex in our budget is the council-wide
one
and we'll continue to do as long as i
can as long as we can afford to but it
won't be prudent not to
yeah i fully get that
uh just on the council tax i was
interested in the um the section in in
the report um that term
the
um
you've got a surplus in effect so
if i'm understanding that
right you
you forecast the percentage of council
tax that you're going to be able to
collect
and that's the figure that goes into the
budget
and then
if you get more than that
that
extra bit is treated as a surplus and
comes in for
um
special handling
in it i just wondered what what um
what percentage
uh collection do you budget for what did
you actually achieve in in the this year
the year that we're looking at
here
and my second point on cancer tax
they
it says
that the um
a certain amount of that surplus will be
released in in
2324 so in other words not into this
financial year the current financial
year but
the next one and i just wondered why
there's that
year's delay in that money being
available
i think just in terms of the collection
question um
prior to kovid
as an authority we we budgeted to
collect just in excess of 99 of all
council tax income
that's not necessarily in year
collection because
in year collection for example this year
i think and i'll confirm the numbers
council of wetton i think india
collection was about
97.5 but i'll confirm that
what we budgeted so
that was prior to cover that we budgeted
to collect nine just over 99 percent of
all our council tax revenues
um we took a view going into call with
that
we may have difficulties collecting at
that level
so we reduce our overall and ultimate
collection rate down to about 98
um
and obviously you'll see that the
surpluses have risen
uh on that account so that suggests that
we've we've collected better than we
were budgeting but i'll confirm the
numbers separately if that's okay i
think just in terms of the timing
what we do every year is we
we set our budget in february
and at that point we say we make the
estimate of what we're going to take out
of the collection fund and that amount
is fixed
if we
collect a different amount at year end
2122 it was bigger than that that goes
into a surplus
but
if that surplus is only risen
after the february date that we set the
new budget
it will go the year after so there's
just real timing lags on when
you can take that surplus to your budget
so had we projected that surplus halfway
through the year
we could have
we could have put that into the 22 23
budget and we did in part
but the surplus at year end was better
so
that won't get released now until 23 24
because we didn't project it early
enough
so
fairly complex procedure in terms of
anything on the collection from but it's
all around timings and when when we set
the budget and what we have to declare
what we're going to take out
thank you
thank you lloyd
i was just going to ask about the
underspends
that's
within the budget
uh from various services including
children's
few
um
is it about 385 but you're spending 486
on agency staff
i suppose the question i'm asking is if
we're spending that money on agency
staff and
we are recruiting i know
to it
how far is the recruitment gone
um
to reduce
that spend on agency staff
um
and
what impact it's not just on this
service but wherever on the
services where you've got numbers spend
on staffing what is the impact on the
service delivery
and i'm sorry i haven't read the
executive report yet i was trying to do
that
no i think it's a really relevant
question and i like i say we
to react to a budget projected budget
overspend which we did
part way through the year we were
projected this overspend that was in the
region of two and a half million
the majority what i said the majority
probably about 80 million pound is spent
on salary related costs for the council
so whether you're looking to try and
mitigating in your position that's
developing and you immediately go and
look at your staffing and what could you
do to control some of that so
we did bring measures in
to try to
avoid external recruitment where we
could
uh mindful of frontline delivery where
we we didn't invoke those similar
measures we needed to get staff in but i
just think
and i can't speak specifics necessarily
but i think the level of underspending
on staff across not just social care
services but across all back office
services
it's it's fairly staggering to be honest
um
i just think it does
it does impact service delivery but i
think we're really mindful that where
it's front line
we're obviously trying to get people in
but i know diane would be saying well we
do struggle in getting social care
workers
and jill would say the same
and that's obviously pushing up the need
for agency staff unfortunately i think
one of the things i was mindful of when
we started looking at budgets for 23 24
is
what what can we learn from 2122 so
we know what pressures we've got in the
system but
is this staffing under spend something
but are we overreacting our staffing
budget and i think
what's coming out of the early period
monitoring is the fact that
i think there's been a push on vacancies
so
when i'm looking and pressing well
have we got a number that we could
potentially take out a budget
to reflect this underspend on staffing
it feels like that
it's not to the same level which
reflects an element to fill in those
posts
more recently than and quicker than
probably what we did in 2122
but
it does impact service delivery but i
couldn't answer specifically
um
because the other thing is as you've uh
alluded to about the page um
for the staff as well
it's
fit some areas and particularly
specialists particularly social workers
um
how do we manage to attract people to
come and fill those vacancies
um
i suppose i'm asking because i know
um
it it's a difficult area to recruit to
um so you must often have to offer some
kind of incentives presumably yeah i i i
think we've just stabbed
recently when i say recently over the
last month probably about a month ago
um diane brought a paper to the
leadership team to to compare obviously
we know we've got difficulties in
attracting and
recruiting staff particularly in social
care
had compared rates of pay across
different bands of social workers across
gm
um
and that benchmarking
was considered and i think
these factors like market supplements
that were considered with the v and and
looking at where whether our banding
structures are right to to incentivize
people to want to work at trafford so i
i think it's recognized and she is doing
things on that and i i think that was
that was a an agreement as an approach
because i know we were looking at well
how do we fund that
um and i and i think one of the the
things we considered was
we know we have vacancies across
the
across all our service areas and it's
the extent that can some of our
vacancies cover
more focus recruitment in some of the
areas where we really need to get it in
so
that's something we've been looking at
thanksgiving any further questions
council carter
i'm gonna be like a cracked record with
looking forward rather than back um
if i might um presumably at a point in
time for 2223
an assumption of the rate of inflation
was made in an assumption on the
settlement for
public sector workers was made
have you calculated
in the light of further developments
is your assumption on inflation looking
realistic and if not what sort of impact
might that we'll be looking at in the
future and
is your assumption on public sector pay
realistic and if not
what sort of impact might that have in
the overall budget context
i think
it's in terms of the assumptions on pay
when we set a budget that was set at two
percent
um
we're not alone on that we do benchmark
across gm what's everybody else doing
um
so we're budgeted at two percent
uh
we made an estimate in the out turn
report that that percentage is very
likely to increase we've obviously seen
the unison
paid demands coming at i think it was
inflation or a
flat rate
2 000 pound i think
um
so that four percent if when you see the
period two monitor and you'll see
there's a section on inflation that sets
out where our thinking currently is
so the figures that we've reported here
at four million
inflation impacts have gone to six
um
just to
contextualize that one percent extra on
pay cost is about eight hundred thousand
pounds
um
but
what we're really considering now and i
think the taxing thing for us is
government said at the moment
they're not going to support authorities
have to live on their own means and and
and balanced without our help that's
what they've said i know we've had a
dialogue with the government departments
and i and i think the government
department's trying to understand
nationally what these impacts mean so
they've spoken to trafford they've
spoken to a lot of authorities
the real challenge we've got is
if inflation's
at this six million pound figure
um and you'll see in the out turn report
we set a risk reserve a side of three
million pound and yes i've heard you've
got contingencies yes we have but we've
got 12 months of activity to to
accommodate within the budget as well
it just gives us that real concern that
if we don't get support what do we do in
terms of service delivery through the
year what do we do in terms of use of
reserves and what do we do in terms of
maintaining an element of resilience
when we've got a three-year budget plan
for 23.4 to do so it's just that real
pressure that we've got at the moment
and it's we're working on best estimates
but yeah and we've refined them um
within this that period to monitor but
it's it's a pressure
any more questions
that's great
sorry i got some of the column
sorry yeah hiding away in the corner um
i just want to come back to um staffing
retention just for a second i know that
market supplements like the one
you mentioned before uh help in the
short term but all borrowers presumably
in great manchester will be facing the
same
pressures on social particularly on
social care retention so what happens
when we're
further down the line they respond with
their own market supplements we're back
where we
we are now and is there anything we can
be doing to prepare for that in the
meantime
i think it's i think again it's a really
good point cause i made the same one clt
that
you catch up but then at what stage do
you lose pace again
um
i just think that's difficult
especially difficult when you've got a
limited market of staff
because if you have got that it could be
that perpetual cycle come to and i think
it's just one that we've got to watch
i'll take that back to diane
um and get a view and feedback to you
separately that's okay
anymore
ahead
and it's prompted by something i heard
on the radio when i was stuck in traffic
on the way here tonight
and it was a comment being made by
some expert or other about the energy
market and
she said actually in this country we're
not yet shouting the need to reduce
the demand for energy in the light of
all the pressures including the
ukraine russia situation
um and
clearly the council will be a bigger
energy consumer i just wondered brent
sorry i forgot to put my microphone i
don't know
i don't know if
our listeners need me to repeat what
i've said so far but i won't
um
i presume somebody's doing some work on
on forecasting the the impact of the
increase in in energy costs have you got
a scale of the problem that that
trafford
faces with that particular element of
the
current uh you know in price increase
situation that we're in
just yeah just speaking
in respect to the council so not not
including schools not including trafford
leisure but just in respect to the
council
energy bills
broadly in the region of 1.6 million
i think
the gas
element of that is about 25
electrics
the remainder obviously we've got the
street lighting is a big concept with
the electric
the working assumption at the moment is
that
those energy bills will double for 22.23
um
budget planning for 23 24 is a little
bit tricky because
it's
what will then get baked in as a price
increase
um
going back to pay that will i've never
seen pay go down so you assume whatever
we get this year we'll get baked in
another two with another pay rise next
year but energy
if if we're seeing a double in this year
i i don't know is
one of the things we may factor into the
plan and we'll have to monitor it
throughout the year is do we think that
may taper down a little bit
as years go on that but
we're watching we're watching in the
morning working assumption at the moment
it doubles in
for energy in 22 23
and continues but we're mindful as well
that would probably think there's a
realism to that the energy may well
taper off a little bit but we'll wait
and see
okay thank you
thanks for that okay go and move on then
to item 12 the sip for financial
management code is that you again graham
yeah it is yeah
i'll just page through the wrong these
budget reports aren't
oh my god
i think
i brought this report
um
this evening i think
sit for
brought out this
the the financial management code and
probably about two years ago
um
and it was i suppose in a reaction to
a number of authorities who who in
effect
administered things incorrectly um poor
practices up and down the country around
financial management
um
and i think it's it's really
to try and tighten up the financial
management um
approach that we've got
i suppose
when i saw this what was quite new to
roll last year it was a breath of fresh
air for me to be able to go through this
code which
basically what we've
what we've got within the code is
there's a number of principles and a
number of
standards
so this this is what they will call
minimum standards that we would expect
you to adhere to
so that they're looking at things like
your leadership team your chief
financial officer
what your governance arrangements and
your reporting arrangements are
how do you set your budget um and how
you how you monitor and report and
engage with stakeholders so
i could spend all night going through
the spreadsheet and the checklist that
we work through but i think
what was quite
refreshing was that
in a lot of cases working through this
chord that
i did feel we were relatively in a good
position
um that's not to say they weren't areas
where we can look to improve
and i think
the fm code is it's not just something
we're looking at
and bringing to you now i think it's
something that
we've identified
the under 2122 issues that we've got to
improve on we will review again in 22 23
have we addressed the issues from 21 22
or are there any new areas so i think
a really useful checklist for me
being a new treasurer but i think
overall findings i think that came out
and i'll just summarize a few of them
and these are things that we're going to
develop on i think
there was an issue on reserves reporting
and i think there's been a transparency
of how we've reported on reserves
over the last 18 months
was one area but i think
other areas that we just need to look at
is how we
maintain our financial management skill
base across the council that's
not just
our staff our finance staff our budget
holders but our members as well so i
think there's a little piece there to
make sure that
we're as up-to-date as we can be i think
what we'll try to do again is
refresh and roll out all our budget
holder training which i think is pretty
crucial for us our directors support me
and support our finance teams in
managing budgets so i think there's a
training piece there
um
one of the issues we've got as a finance
team
i think is around succession planning
we're not getting any younger
so i think i think
we're still we're looking at bringing
trainees in and
it's difficult though because we go back
to the issue about staffing and
recruitment craic
it's no different in finance
um we've been out a few times for the
treasury management role
our treasury manager retired after 33
years service at trafford about four
months ago been out twice couldn't
recruit
so
we've got to be mindful how do you keep
these services going bringing in new
board when it's really difficult to um
to do that
[Music]
so succession planning is quite key to
us
i think just some of the other areas
i think we could be stronger how we link
our capital planning in with our revenue
budget planning
um
i think that's something we probably
need to develop but i know richard rose
building up his property team
and we've already seen strides um and
positive movements in that direction
and i think the other big area
and it is a big area is how we
govern
and report on our council's joint
ventures
um
nottingham
who were an authority who had quite a
number of joint venture companies
some of them set up for no reason
whatsoever
not reported on and i think
we've got an investment management board
we bring things through our monitors but
i think there's an element of
transparency that we can improve on as
to how we report on the performance of
our companies
how we control our companies and govern
the meetings that we go to and again
now rich is developing his team we've
made strides in actually setting that
governance and more stronger governance
up in those areas so
i think useful to bring to the committee
tonight just to show that we're not
resting on our laws and we're trying to
move on and improve on what i think was
quite as reasonable but i'm not going to
say a good base i can't say that canon
but i think it was quite reasonably what
we've done in administ in in previous
years as a financial management
discipline so
um happy to take any questions if
anyone's got any sure
thanks christopher lloyd
what's the relationship between um
accounting audit and scrutiny
and the reason why i asked that is
because i was asked about the children's
services
and um obviously the children's services
have been because we're monitoring in
in in a way because it's um
a sort of
we're looking at it because it doesn't
help our reports
um scrutiny are also looking at
well it seems to me the scrutiny look at
things um for example
uh the new
um
integrated care board so they've got a
work program we've got a work program
where do we join up i mean
that's
that's the question
i think could be looked at really that
relationship that we have scrutiny
because quite a lot of work we have is
just
for
um noting
where actually scrutiny can do
things
and i don't know whether we could have a
look at that because
it's that value for money and everything
else
um
that we look at
and the other thing is um another
question
um
the report's really
comprehensive um and really interesting
but your action plans on the right hand
side of that you know you recognize what
it needs to be done but when is it going
to be done by it i think i would like to
have a look at
actual
um dates on that so we can see the
progress that is has been made
i think just uh
the points in reverse i think what we
can do and i think it's
this is the first time we've reported on
this so i think what what would probably
want to do is maybe part way through the
year mark if we can maybe build an
updated session in
um
just just to report back on the progress
we've made in some of those areas
um
[Music]
so we can take that away i think in
terms of the relationship with
scrutiny
obviously we had the scrutiny review by
the
was it the
center for scrutiny or public scrutiny
or something like that that's how you
can improve the effectiveness of that i
think
i think it's just understanding and
looking at them remits into the two
groups because obviously there's
differences there around
your remit around the council audit and
i would report on on the finances
they've obviously got a remit around
value for money and other decisions made
um
yeah i think it's quite a difficult
question really
just to understand
how you how you get the benefit of the
two without duplication
in in the fact that you can't have
duplication because actually one of the
things about scrutiny because i've been
a scrutiny member
and being an executive member as well
you often get the same people reporting
to the same thing and it goes round and
round in a circle and i'm not asking for
that
but do scrutiny for example taking um
some of the um
costs um
implications of things and and stuff
like that
and and i think
you know that it's scrutiny
have mentioned scrutiny and um
accountant and i just wondered if it's
possible
just to have a chat
about
um
if there's any way that we can
um augment each other rather than
duplicating because i agree with you
um about duplication
um
i think if i just explained scrutiny's
role in in finance um
when they set their work program and
obviously they
i think the big piece of work they do is
around the scrutiny around budget
proposals
so from
autumn onwards there's a number of
scrutiny meetings looking at the budget
process the assumptions
drilling down into the
the directorate
approaches to their budget planning
so so that's me and i and i've sat on
those scrutinies and
there are there's not duplication from
what i've seen at this
from that level
and i i think it's that role of scrutiny
in terms of
how we're maximizing the bang for our
book how we delivering council
priorities to the best effect you with
the with the scarce resources we've got
and i
i think there's a
fair definition there as to
the differences and the reasons why
we've got the audit committee that's got
its own terms of reference
um
scrutiny has got that separate
view of the budget through a different
lens and
different approach to that
yeah okay
sorry and uh at the last point up this
is the last point i'll make on that
if you look at um
scrutiny
and they did the children's
services but i'm not sure how much they
were looking at
um sort of
if you like the accounting bits if
do you know what i mean
i mean
the other thing is
um i suppose it's the decisions that are
made that i think that i'm looking at on
what the relationship is should i for
example is an account nor this
member
should i be looking at this the scrutiny
role
that they're doing on for example
children's services which is the biggest
thing that's happened
um
to us um
i suppose that's what i'm looking at and
that it will be the last point other
than to say that i think all members
need training in
accounting audits
for the council it's not just uh budget
holders
because actually uh
i'm not sure
i think it needs to be a bit more
widespread
in a way because
it the finances are really really
important and the fact that we also have
um
we're not rich for
by any means and all the pressures that
are coming on um to everybody and i know
it goes to executive uh the budget
monitoring report and i know it goes to
um scrutiny where we do it
um
books
it just
there is something in the in in terms of
with a scrutiny work program that's
developed we've got an accounts and
audit committee work program that's
developed
and i suppose that the formulation of
them work programs
with the involvement of officers we've
got that responsibility to make sure
big ticket items
are not missed out across those two
committees and i
you you're writing that
we know what's happening with
with children's with schools we know
what's coming down the line with adult
social care around charge and reform
these things are massive
and the the implications will be massive
and i
we've obviously had three years of an
asset investment strategy and i i will i
will accept that
audit committees looked at that i know
it's on the risk register so when we
brought updates last year
scrutiny committees all so looked at
that
but i
i think you're right and i i'd be i'd be
wanting to play and look at them two
work programs just to make sure there's
a synchronization between the two
to make sure there's no duplication and
i think
the issue around
member training and financial aspects of
training i think
i suppose it's just understanding where
we pitch that and what we what we do i
know we do the final accounts training
um we do treasury management training
but obviously because of the remit of
the audit committee on treasury
management around final accounts
i'm more than happy to sit down with you
in the chair just to think if there are
any other areas um
that we would want to
bring in and i suppose and i've asked
the chair of scrutiny a similar thing
um
for example training around investment
strategies and things like that so i
think it's
that's probably part of the work that
i've got to do in terms of that elected
member side so i can take that away
that's so that's fine
anything else
yeah
graham i'd just like to say i thought
the seafood report was really excellent
you know there's a a lot of areas that
you've covered and there's an awful lot
of work you can see that that's gone
into that and just a couple of questions
from an awareness point of view please
um
longer term because obviously it's only
just been introduced is this something
we could use to benchmark possibly with
other councils to
learn and see how we can
improve and then also is there
any other consequences longer term if we
don't comply
with everything to a certain level you
know as this progresses
i think in terms of benchmarking
it's probably something we would want to
look at um
i think where authorities are where
obviously first time we've done it
and i think we're probably advanced
listening to other treasurer colleagues
who've not actually reported any outputs
from this but i think it's something we
can look at i think
implications and non-compliance i think
well you you look at the likes of
nottingham you look at the special
interest reports that these authorities
about we don't want to go there
um
so
i i don't think it's an option that i
would want to consider non-compliance i
don't think it's recommended for anybody
yeah that's great thank you
thank you
thanks sir graham coming on now to item
13 audit assurance report for january to
march 2022 i think that's you mark
okay thank you chair
um it's the first of two um audit update
reports um
this first one covers the last quarter
of the year the work we did slightly
briefer than the usual coursely updates
because a lot of analysis in the in the
next agenda item covering the annual
audit report
um
but just just for the benefit of new
members um there's a reference in the
report to audit opinions given
um for each main audit review we do we
have um
a series of audit opinion levels um four
in total which aligns with sit for good
practice
um ranging from low
low or no assurance for areas of concern
up to substantial assurance where we
we've found effective controls in place
so it's just there's a bit more detail
on that in in in both reports
um
in terms of um work we've done in the
period there were six final reports
issued where opinion levels were given
um
one of those uh was a substantial four
reasonable and there was one limited
assurance review where we found um quite
a few improvements required
um
there's a summary of those each of those
reviews um on in section five on page
one six five um so that you'll see the
reviews included there was there's one
around information governance and
processes around data breaches
um there were a couple of it management
reviews also one covering highways
inspection um one round
letter states
um which was the review where we had a
limited opinion
um that was really some ways it's an
interim piece of work because we plan to
do further work on that
we've done the audit at a period where
the function was transferring from amy
uh to an in-house arrangement
so we
from the work we did at that point we
highlighted a number of areas for
improvement which
which the in-house the place directorate
team fully aware of um
and are addressing so
we plan to have further follow-up
meetings with them during the year and
ultimately some more detailed um audit
testing towards the end of the year just
to see those improvements have been
established
um
we also issued a number of other draft
reports that i'll formally can bring
back to the next
committee where they've reached final
stage
and then also on page 167
there's a brief section there on some
other activity
uh during the period in addition to the
audits we completed so you see the likes
of the strategic risk register work
which there's of course an item on this
agenda on that
a piece of work we did throughout 21-2
which has now come to an end for us
around supporting other services around
the payment of covert 19 business grants
and we had a role around providing
various checks
uh
in that
to provide some more assurance that
they were being paid appropriately um
that work has taken up quite a bit of
time um but has now come to an end so
hopefully it would free up uh for for
other planned work
um also last quarter we brought the
um in the january summary course we
brought the audit plan for the year
ahead to the committee
um
and then in terms of january to march
the sort of response we had to our audit
work um
all the recommendations made in those
six reports they were all accepted by
management
which which was pleasing
um and also we did follow up work of
previous audits we'd done which included
the data breaches work but also we
requested updates from managers
on previous audits we'd done and we
found on the whole
most recommendations had been
implemented with a couple a couple in
progress
there's more analysis in the the annual
audit report
on that
and also around performance against the
audit plan i'll pick that up in the next
item as well
so in terms of the next quarterly update
we give
for april to june i'll bring that to the
next committee meeting
okay thanks well any questions on on
that only quite a report
coastal wetland and council of light
good question if it may mark on the um
the um
inspection you did it of the highways
um
activities
um did you
test them at all on their
um
[Music]
assessment of
roads requiring repair or did you just
accept the
the
basis that they operate on
yeah we we didn't do any sort of
physical testing
or in the
we made sure there was some basis for
their process
uh over time that then they've got a
planned
series of roads around that uh and
that's where we did highlight to make
sure everything was being covered as
appropriate that i think a flag there
there were a small number that had been
missed out um just for historical
purposes and were record-keeping that
had not got onto the list so we flagged
that up but we didn't go into detail in
the order around the you know the ins
and outs of the of each road
[Music]
um it's about the limited um
uh
that you've got on the left estates
place
and i
think i i would like some more
information about what that would
include
because um
which leases
etc lease renewals rent reviews
and rent collection
and also um
how long
it it's obviously taking some time to do
this it's just if there's any loss to
the council
um as a result of
the transfer or hasn't been collected or
hasn't been done
with the previous with amy um i have to
say that um
it's probably better that it's now come
back in
to trafford so that we've got more
control of it as well
so i'm pleased about that and i know
it's next year that you do but could i
just have a bit more information before
then if that's
if what you know anyway i'll get a hold
of some sort of latest position
on the properties yeah
okay
can we pass on then to item 14 which is
the annual report for mark again
okay so that this report will set sets
out the the work of uh internal internal
audit throughout 21 22.
and it's a requirement we produce this
report
uh to meet the public sector internal
audit standards
um and a key element of the report is a
requirement for us to produce an annual
audit opinion
um i've talked before about the
individual audit opinions so this is the
need so give an overall one as well
um
in in terms of internal audit work again
as background we've got an internal
audit charter uh and strategy that we
brought to the march committee so we
looked to to conduct all our work in
accordance with that um
in in terms of our work for the year we
gave an opinion um on page 177
uh section 2.1
um and that's uh it does acknowledge
they've been the continue particularly
at the start of the year some some
disruption and and obviously not just
for internal audit situation across the
council
um so that did did cause some um
sort of changes to the audit plan
but we still managed to cover a wide
period of work a wide range of work um
across the audit plan so i felt we could
still provide a full audit opinion
um and the overall conclusion was that
we
would give a reasonable level of
assurance um that the control
environments operate into a satisfactory
standard
and the report sets out various factors
um
that led to that opinion um
based on individual reviews we did um
management uh responses to our work and
also seeing progress in implementing
previous recommendations and also
gathering assurance
from other areas the likes of that come
to this committee likes the budget
monitoring
um
so on on page 180 there is a summary of
the opinion levels we gave
during the year which you'll see a
description of what we mean by each each
level of assurance and you can see there
there was um there were six substantial
nine reasonable and there was there was
just the one limited assurance and the
other the other reviews there with three
that they they did it also indicated
good progress being made um or one of
those reviews was purely consultancy
review to provide advice as opposed to
providing
an
opinion um
and we reported to the committee through
the year in the different quarters
um so this report basically consolidates
all those early reports we've given um
on page 200
uh you'll see
it starts a sort of summary of the work
for the year
in terms of areas covered and also um
time spent
on that and then the appendix after that
appendix b
um
then lists the individual audit reviews
in terms of the reports we issued or or
further work planned
um
just going back
to earlier in the port um page 181
covers as i did in the quarterly update
um some details of other other work we
we contributed to
during the year so the likes of the
strategic risk register which a regular
item for the committee
um also work around anti-fraud
um although the there's a dedicated
fraud team that that would do the
majority of that we provide a
coordinating role in relation to the
national fraud initiative
um
and also doing some work um helping to
feed into aspects of the annual
governance statement
and also we'll we'll consider the draft
version for any any any amount possible
amendments before that's final
um and as i said earlier various work
completing grant checks
um which which did take up considerable
time and various of the guidance
produced during during the year um
i won't cover and there's a lot of
sections there for the different
categories of work and starts on page
182
it goes through the different areas
we've covered likes of financial systems
schools
counter fraud work risk management
procurement i.t
and then a number of a number of service
audits the likes of that highways
review just talked about
um
where applicable for each of those
audits that we make recommendations
where we feel we can make improvements
and um
and again there's analysis for the whole
year in terms of acceptance of our
recommendations and implementation of
them and and we found in section
5.2 of the report
um there's
i think it indicates that most
recommendations um were implemented
during the year uh i think there is of
the 50 yeah 52 out of 53
implemented during the year
sorry accepted uh during the year
um and then in terms of implementation
of audit
recommendations um we've found there
this was 95 percent have either been
implemented full or implemented in in
part or in progress
um
where we we feel as more works are done
to be done we've put that in in this
year's audit plan as well so obviously
likes the letter states we've talked
about we'll we'll do more work in that
area as an example
um
in terms of performance against the plan
overall that starts on page 197
of the report
it has been a challenging year as 2021
was in terms of completing audits and we
have found
particularly with changes over the last
few months with more staff coming into
the buildings audit work it becomes a
little bit easier in terms of um being
able to able to progress work but i i
think we we've certainly tried to
progress things as best as we could
during the period but we have worked
with other services to reschedule uh
reviews so obviously recognizing
pressures
on other services as well um
as i mentioned earlier some extra time
spent around grant's work um
over and above what we what we'd have
planned to to have done
um but we've we've linked him with each
direction to produce the march audit
audit plan which which contains some of
those reviews that got deferred
um
as a as a final point as well and we
talked about standards before the fm
code will internal audit uh needs to
work to to a set of standards and the
site in the public sector internal audit
standards
um so we we
periodically will in fact annually do an
internal review of
of where how we think we're doing
against them but there's also an
expectation that every five years
there's a full external independent
review
um we last had one that got reported in
2018 to the committee which sit for uh
completed
and we've agreed for sitfor to do
further review uh that's due to take
place in march 23
um so we'll be preparing for that and it
will involve some input certainly from
the likes of the audit committee chair
um the sit for assessor will will speak
to a number of of of officers around the
council as well as part of their review
so would report to to the committee when
we have findings on that which i would
think would be the probably the
equivalent meeting of this next year
first meeting of the year
um
just as a final point
obviously making progress in the current
year
um and feel as though that has we've
accelerated things a bit as conditions
have improved
so we'll bring it we'll bring that
update report to the to the next meeting
in september
any questions on the annual report
i thought interesting and pleasing to
see that paragraph on in the procurement
section um about uh cabinet office
uh asking for a review to um
see but the situation with suppliers
from russia and belarus and to with a
view to them being terminated so it was
uh i'm pleased to see it there i'm glad
you didn't have any uh
dirty work to do
with it it's very encouraging both ways
it was a useful piece of work in terms
of um the star authorities coming
together because it started off with
stockport doing a piece of work with
star and they sort of created a
framework that the rest could work to so
it made it a little bit easier to to go
through that
carter
thanks chad um thank you there's a awful
lot in that um i think just looking at
that as you were speaking that
the total number of audit reports
completed was fewer than what was
originally in the plan
how does that look in 2223 are you
looking at doing fewer
so you hit the target or will you do
more or how does that work out please um
the target we have for 22.3 i mean every
year
it depends on the nature of the reviews
as well because there can be
more larger reviews
say that take 20 days or whatever
compared to a five day um
i would say at the moment our target for
uh 22 3 was slightly less than the one
for 21 2.
i think being realistic looking at the
last few years
and resources
but we set a target much more
challenging
higher than the figure we achieved in
21-2
so we set a 32
uh target and at the moment it's
it's on track at this stage um so based
on april to july thank
you that's it thanks very much
we're on to item 15 which is on the
supplementary agenda strategic risk
register 20 22 23.
um so yeah the latest uh strategic risk
register report that
clt
reviewed last week
so again an update on each of the 15
strategic risks
on the register
one i suppose one key change in terms of
a change in risk score since we brought
the report to the last meeting in march
um with the risk around the disruption
as a result of covid um i suppose
reflecting the national position
um has decreased from a high to a medium
risk uh although the report has
acknowledged you know still being wary
of
future risks around it but uh
for this update that has gone down
um
the charts on 2.6 the two charts
that just reflects that change with that
one risk um
going down so there are seven in the in
the highest risk category there
um
the highest risk being the uh the
medium-term
financial position which has the has the
25
score
no change from from previous about the
considerable update of developments
around actions being taken
around that a lot was was discussed
earlier on that
um
so we will be giving further updates
during the year and one thing i'm saying
from the discussion around the work
program earlier if there are um areas of
risk that you you feel like it would be
beneficial to have a bit more detail on
a particular meeting
we could look to to add those to the
work program as well um it's something i
can i can discuss as well on an ongoing
basis with with the chair and vice chair
so if anybody has has any areas they
wish to
you know have
for consideration on that
[Music]
thanks mark any comments
on the risk assessment michael my castle
button
[Music]
uh just to just
ask really is the um
in the time that um
while i was off the council
that's when covid hit and it would have
been
um
an interesting
fly on the wall experience to see
everybody reaching for the risk
registers and seeing what
um
they needed to do i'm just wondering
again
looking ahead now so
what sort of work is going into
um
coordinating the learnings from the
covid experience in terms of
uh risk registers because it's not just
this
res rich register is that there's the
departmental
ones as well and i just wondered
um what sort of
work is going into
bringing that to together
because i'm sure there must be a whole
host of stuff that should be harnessed
yeah saying that the time of the
outbreak um the the strategic risk
register yes it gained one specific new
risk around covid but there was a
general
update around most of the areas that had
that
considerations around it whether it be
finance health and safety
um
one one of the the key uh
risks on here that's been on here a
while is around business continuity
and there have been a lot of
developments around that over the last
year
um in terms of being able to cope
with different situations and scenarios
so that's prob that's probably sort of a
good headline one and it's still on the
risk register at the moment but that's
one where work is being done and
progressed around individual services
having their own um business continuity
plans and doing impact assessments
which hopefully we see is as a as a big
improvement over the well maybe over the
time we've had covered you know probably
one of the
the really good improvements as a result
of that um but yes over time
i mean each director would will need to
consider its you know its own risks
going forward yeah
being coordinated as far as you know
is it
you know an agenda out there
across the council
um i know um
like groups um
the the update we get on this uh covid
risk refers to various groups and
activity across the different uh across
the different directorates
um
again i know we haven't had a
specific detailed update on that to the
committee other than other than here but
whether it's something
um could
we could consider for more detail and
exactly get to grips with what what's
happening in individual services
um i suppose consideration of risk going
forward around covert is another thing
but
certainly i mean from my experience
around the business continuity side
seems to have been the the obvious one
um in terms of changes being made
okay any other questions
councillor thompson but rose and then
thank you and
it's like a little bit more detail
around the freedom of information
requests and the sa sars
because it
it looks like we were doing really
really well and up till february
and then something happened in february
where we've had a lot of complaints to
the
information officer and i'd like some
more detail about that and whether there
was a common theme in in those
complaints
and whether that's something we could
look a bit more in detail yeah
we recently
had had this update and that you noticed
the the variations and it's something i
did flag actually that i thought it
might be useful for the committee to get
that more detailed information so it was
one of the conversations we had earlier
um
that may be good for the either the next
meeting or the november meeting one
coming up to have perhaps an item on
information governance that picks up on
those things you mentioned maybe data
breaches that you know perhaps pick up
on those issues within the register and
get that further detail yeah
thank you chair i've got two questions
i'll do the second first because it kind
of relates to uh rosie's question so i
like to
note and approve the um significant
reduction in outstanding sars that looks
like doing some good work done
do you anticipate that we will get close
to the 90 percent target set for
fois
i'm not too sure in terms of the next
few months where
how close would be i know there's a lot
of actions underway to to achieve that
um but i'd say
maybe it would be useful to get that
detail for the committee maybe for the
september meeting yes please check and
first question um
on the first risk around medium term
finances it's good to see that
the establishment of the finance and
change programme
structure is put in there as a
mitigation
can i ask is is that work
the scrutiny of that work fall under
this committee and or
core scrutiny
i think
i think once we've reported the draft
budget report to exec in october i think
that'll perform part of the scrutiny
work
that we'll look at that draft draft
budget position and also the work that's
been done so far so i think it'll fall
under scrutiny
okay thanks because it's kind of
the big medium term game in town so it's
encouraging to hear that thank you
nobody else okay thanks very much can we
go on then to uh item 16 the accounts
and audit annual report to council for
2122.
okay the uh so we've put together a
summary of the work
for the uh committee for
uh last year
and we've agreed uh chairs agreed we'll
go to the full council meeting next week
uh with that report summarizes the work
that was undertaken and provides
assurance that the committee uh
completed work in in line with its terms
of reference
um and and details the items discussed
at each each meeting um to under each of
those areas of the terms of reference
so say yeah that that will report will
go to council next week
okay thanks mark any comments on that
we'll get chance at council next week
anyway okay just to record our thanks
for the preparation and delivery of that
thanks
yes sir every year a lot of work goes
into all these things
item 17 is the council audit work
program
okay thank you chair obviously we've had
some discussion during the meeting
around that which is useful uh to
consider and we'll
you've got a work programme uh for this
meeting but terms we've discussed the fm
code be a further update on that later
in the year
and also an update on information
governance
um but you see the the this report does
cover quite a number of items
to cover through the year
um but it remains sort of flexible and
to be added to
um
and if if there are anything in
september november february we feel we
we should add it it takes into account
national requirements the accounts and
audit regulations so there's the
approval of the accounts
and ags by
november
um and and it does reference some
training as well that's going to be
undertaken by finance outside of the
meeting so including the one uh coming
up around
the the accounts
um but i would assume further items will
it's a starting point really the work
programmers we can add to things
uh and then we'll include it on the
agenda
at each meeting for for discussion
thanks
can we note that but by all means
anybody feel feel free to uh
submit something to mark that you might
you'd like to see included in the
program for the coming year
okay
thanks very much
i think subject to urgent business which
i've not been notified of any urgent
business
that's the end of the meeting we might
get home before the uh cloud's burst i
think
thank you
[Music]
thank you are there any officers here
who know anything about i.t or having a
responsibility for it
may have a quick question